[Musica]
salve mi chiamo milena zone che sono un
insegnante della scuola primaria sono
responsabile dell'innovazione senza
zaino nell'istituto di pirri senza zaino
è un'esperienza scolastica che è
iniziata tre anni fa nelle nostre scuole
per spiegare il perché di questa scelta
mi piace citare una frase di marco orsi
che l'ideatore del senza zaino che rende
perfettamente l'idea di quelli che sono
gli interrogativi basilari ci siamo mai
chiesti se tutto quello che noi
proponiamo i modelli che noi proponiamo
ai nostri ragazzi sono veramente in
grado di promuovere competenza autonomia
e apprendimento
questi modelli sono veramente in grado
di renderli attenti e con uno sguardo
curioso verso quello che il mondo
quindi partendo da questi interrogativi
abbiamo deciso di mettersi in di
metterci in gioco
cos'è il primo aspetto che colpisce
quando si entra in una aula senza zaino
sicuramente è quella che noi definiamo
l'organizzazione spaziale
l'organizzazione spaziale in che senso
sono scomparsi i banchi ma nelle nostre
aule ci sono dei tavoli quadrati dove
possono lavorare fino a sei bambini
i mobiletti a giorno hanno preso il
posto di quelli che erano gli armadi con
le ante chiusi dove i bambini
non potevano avere libero accesso ai
materiali al loro interno mera eravamo
noi insegnanti che prendevamo il
materiale lo davamo ai bambini nelle
nostre aule non funziona più così i
bambini possono avere libero accesso a
tutto quello che si trova all'interno
delle nostre aule l'angolo docente ha
preso il posto di quella che era la
cattedra la cattedra quindi non occupa
più una posizione centrale nelle nostre
aule ma noi insegnanti lavoriamo ai
tavoli insieme ai bambini uno spazio
molto importante all'interno delle
nostre aule viene occupato dall'agorà
l'agorà è un luogo che si presta a
molteplici attività ad inizio giornata
noi la usiamo per raccontarci per
parlare del nostro stato d'animo di cosa
abbiamo fatto il giorno prima per
presentare anche quelle che sono le
attività quotidiane o anche la lezione
frontale quindi l'insegnante decide di
presentarla in uno spazio molto raccolto
che quello proprio dell'agorà oppure
durante l'arco della giornata l'agorà
può essere utilizzata singolarmente oa
piccoli gruppi dai ragazzi per leggere
conversare o anche per rilassarsi nelle
aule ci sono anche dei mini laboratori
linguistici scientifici o anche storico
geografici i ricchi di materiali molta
attenzione cura viene riservata anche
quelli che vengono definiti gli spazi
connettivi quelli che solitamente sono
gli spazi di passaggio
quindi non più anditi androni spogli ma
i nostri ambiti nei nostri anni ti
troviamo i tavoli per le ricerche
l'angolo relax l'angolo della pittura in
piedi l'angolo gioco l'angolo lettura e
talvolta anche le agorà perché dove lo
spazio aula è molto ristretto e non
consente la strutturazione dell'agorà
con delle sedute e morbide si decide di
di posizionarlo all'esterno questi spazi
possono essere utilizzati in maniera
libera da tutti i bambini
l'importante è che vengano rispettate
quelle che lo chiamiamo le buche sono le
istruzioni per l'uso che ne scandiscono
proprio l'utilizzo quindi quanti bambini
possono accedere in quello spazio come
deve essere riposto il materiale al loro
interno e così via
l'organizzazione degli spazi quindi come
ambienti di apprendimento si porta
dietro anche quella che l'organizzazione
della pannellistica quindi abbiamo dei
pannelli colorati o in sughero dove
vengono appesi i lavori quotidiani degli
alunni
oppure delle mappe che sintetizzano
l'argomento che in quel momento viene
svolto all'interno della classe ma
troviamo anche le tabelle dei presenti
assenti che vengono gestite dai nostri
alunni nel momento in cui entrano in
classe bambino posizione il bollino
della presenza immensa oppure il
cerimoniere posizione invece l'assenza
del bambino che magari in quella
giornata
non ci sarà a scuola
troviamo anche il planning settimanale
dove sono illustrate all'orario degli
insegnanti l attività il timetable che
scandisce proprio il susseguirsi delle
diverse attività durante la giornata
tutti questi pannelli vengono gestiti
dagli alunni
una volta che i bambini sono stati
abituati abbiamo condiviso insieme tutte
queste regole tutte queste procedure
loro hanno sono autonomi nella loro
gestione
inoltre della pannellistica non possiamo
non citare il famoso semaforo
montessoriano che è appunto regolamenta
la andare in bagno quindi nelle nostre
aule non ci sono più le mani alzate
maestra per favore possa andare
bagno ma basta che il bambino sole vi lo
sguardo controlla il colore e può avere
libero accesso ai ai servizi tutte
queste procedure scandiscono e
accompagnano i vari ritmi della giornata
con una forza comunicativa che è molto
più efficace dell'uso della parola
un altro aspetto che appunto colpisce
all'interno delle nostre aule e proprio
il clima che si respira mentre i bambini
appunto lavorano in autonomia nei tavoli
l'insegnante gira di diversi tavoli
cercando di utilizzare il meno possibile
la voce proprio l'uso della voce è come
dire uno strumento che dobbiamo imparare
a gestire
cerchiamo sempre di utilizzarlo al
minimo e con toni estremamente bassi se
è il caso di richiamare gli alunni
perché magari in quel momento non si
ricordano molto bene il tipo di attività
che stanno facendo e quale comportamento
devono mantenere usiamo quelli che sono
gli strumenti di gestione che vengono
chiamati strumenti di gestione per
esempio il pesce del silenzio o il
serpente del sussurro che dal nome si
capisce bene che cosa suggeriscono di
fare però utilizziamo anche quelli che
noi chiamiamo i messaggi silenziosi dei
cartellini che appoggiamo nei tavoli e
ricordiamo ai bambini e ragazzi
il tipo di attività che stanno facendo e
la cura e l'attenzione che ci devono
mettere ma soprattutto possono essere
anche di feedback positivo in quel
momento quindi ricordare al bambino il
lavoro che sta facendo è che lo sta
svolgendo in una
era adeguata
l'assetto dell'aula quindi come spazio
educativo attraverso appunto alla
disposizione degli arredi la cura di
tutti i materiali che ci sono altro più
interno rende l'aula polifunzionale il
fatto di avere un'aula polifunzionale
permette anno insegnanti anche di
svolgere all'interno di queste aule
delle attività differenziate perché i
ragazzi sono autonomi e responsabili e
riescono a gestire il materiale che c'è
il proprio interno senza dover avere la
supervisione costante di noi insegnanti
per esempio io posso decidere il giorno
di fare una lezione frontale invece che
presentarla all'intera classe
decido di presentarla ad un tavolo
mentre io lavoro a quel tavolo con un
argomento nuovo il resto della classe va
al tavolo del laboratorio per esempio
linguistico prende del materiale già
strutturato già predisposto con le ipo
quindi con le istruzioni per il suo
utilizzo e poi lavorare in piena
autonomia al proprio tavolo senza aver
necessità che ci sia l'insegnante ad
osservare il lavoro che viene svolto le
nostre aule
la cosa che colpisce quando si entra
nelle nostre aule proprio anche la
ricchezza del materiale
quando si parla di materiale non
pensiamo solo al materiale di uso comune
quindi matite penne gomme che sono
condivise perché insieme allo zaino
bambini lasciano anche l'astuccio perché
tutto quello che loro a loro serve
durante l'attività scolastica lo trovano
all'interno delle aule quindi nei nostri
centrotavola quelli che noi chiamiamo
centrotavola che sono posizionati in
ogni tavolo ma quando parliamo di
ricchezza di materiale parliamo anche di
materiale per l'apprendimento delle
competenze linguistiche e matematiche
matematiche questo materiale viene
predisposto da noi insegnanti
attraverso quelle che noi chiamiamo
strumenti di apprendimento
per quanto riguarda il lavoro
differenziato è molto importante perché
nella classe noi ci rendiamo conto che
non tutti hanno gli stessi tempi di
apprendimento quindi poter permettere
agli alunni nello stesso momento di
poter svolgere attività differenti
è un modo anche per gratificarli per
valorizzare quello che loro sanno fare
in quel momento
durante questo percorso come insegnanti
ovviamente abbiamo dovuto abbiamo dovuto
rivedere proprio il nostro modo di fare
scuola
quando abbiamo iniziato con la classe
prima le nostre formatrici ci hanno
supportato e ci hanno invitato suggerito
ad esempio di non utilizzare
immediatamente i quattro caratteri
nell'apprendimento della letto scrittura
ma di iniziare e soprattutto con il
carattere maiuscolo questo carattere si
presenta sempre uguale resta sempre
tutti tutti i simboli hanno la stessa
altezza ed è meno difficoltoso per i
bambini proprio a livello percettivo è
il carattere invece stampato minuscolo
di utilizzarlo esclusivamente per la
lettura
per quanto riguarda invece il corsivo ad
esempio abbiamo usato un approccio molto
graduale bambini li abbiamo fatti per
esempio esercitare prima con degli
strumenti che si trovano all'interno
delle nostre aule per esempio il
quaderno di sabbia quindi valorizzando
proprio quello che il gesto del bambino
la mano e questo sicuramente gli ha
avvantaggiati molto nelle nostre aule
come bambini utilizzano non solo i
quadri aironi utilizzano anche i quadri
notti li chiamiamo così sono dei
quaderni che sono più piccoli hanno
informato inferiore rispetto al quadro
nome in a4 e aiutano il bambino proprio
nella proprio all'inizio nell'approccio
per l'organizzazione spazio del del
foglio cioè non si perdono all'interno
di questo grande foglio bianco
un altro aspetto che curiamo e proprio
la comunità la relazione quindi le
nostre famiglie sono le nostre aule sono
rese molto gradevoli e accoglienti non
solo dal lavoro di noi insegnanti con
insieme con i nostri alunni ma anche dal
l'aiuto che le famiglie ci danno non
solo per esempio nei periodi festivi per
preparare addobbi decorazioni ma anche
proprio nella costruzione di strumenti
nel nostro istituto infatti è in
allestimento quella che viene chiamata
la fabbrica degli strumenti ci alle
famiglie noi insegnanti possiamo
accedervi e costruire degli strumenti di
apprendimento che poi noi o di gestione
che poi noi utilizziamo all'interno
delle nostre aule e gli ambienti proprio
resi ospitali e attraverso quindi colori
arredi favoriscono quindi una nuova
visione della didattica
dell'apprendimento e dello stare bene a
scuola
vorrei concludere il mio intervento
proprio sottolineando un aspetto che per
me è centrale e quello della cura la
cura non solo degli spazi non solo degli
arredi
non solo la cura dei bambini ma la curia
di bambini da parte di noi adulti la
cura dei materiali e degli oggetti che
ci sono all'interno rendono speciale
diciamo così lo stare a scuola
perché è molto importante curare la
relazione perché dobbiamo rendere la
scuola tutte le ore che i nostri ragazzi
passano all'interno delle nostre aule
dei luoghi di apprendimento autentici e
non dei semplici luoghi di passaggio per
quella che poi deve essere la vita
futura perché per loro anche queste vita
non è
dobbiamo attendere un'altra vita ma già
quella che loro stanno passando ogni
giorno all'interno delle nostre aule con
noi
evita quindi vi ringrazio io avvicini
[Applauso]
[Musica]